[Music]
all right joining us now a lot of news
today is counsel to the president our
friend Kellyanne Conway is with us I
want to get to the Eagles before I
cannot take what has been done and said
again and the attacks the first lady's
was standing you have gone through it a
bunk has gone through it where is all
this liberal respect for women because
it seems non-existent and the first lady
keeps putting on statements I'm here I'm
recovering I just had surgery and yes I
was seen in public yesterday I saw some
folks today talking about the fact that
we need to revisit the Equal Rights
Amendment and get that ratified from
it's failed attempt 40 years ago Sean to
prove that women have equal rights and
we are respected how about just starting
to respect each other regardless of
ideology and politics and position and I
just want to say a couple of things and
take it away from me and others and
right back to the first lady I work
closely with her I respect her
enormously
this country is blessed because she is
our first lady at this time I speak one
language is about five less than she
speaks she has accompanied her husband
all over the world helping to represent
this nation and I would tell those
critics to look no further than First
Lady Melania Trump's be best platform to
understand how she thinks the solutions
should go in this nation she talks about
kindness and respect and the social
emotional and physical well-being and
it's horrible of children make better
choices she's out there trying to help
children who feel that they need that
they need assistance that they they feel
like they're being bullied at school
perhaps or they're addicted to drugs
I've traveled with the first lady and
watched her hold those babies who were
born addicted their first breaths in
this world were a struggle because
they're one of the 100 babies born every
day and she's committed to breaking the
back of the neonatal abstinence syndrome
what the way they have treated her is so
over-the-top awful words can't even
describe it
but I don't even like dignifying it by
discussing it too because she's so much
stronger than that she's so much years
are you so much more than her critics in
the naysayers well who cares she's there
with gold lovely
great person Shawn look at the
difference look at the company that the
first lady keeps she's there honoring
gold star families and people are
peddling conspiracy theories that
frankly don't shouldn't be dignified let
me ask your platforms so in the NFL you
can't you can't spike the football you
can't on other players you can't do
certain dances and any gestures they
have all sorts of quote restrictions on
freedom of speech but yet Roger Goodell
and his infinite wisdom you know they
allowed everything that happened last
year people fought bled and died
fighting for under that flag I'm not
against protesting but the NFL does
stifle quote freedom of speech in some
ways here's my point I'm kind of done
with the NFL now they're gonna let
players hide in the locker room which i
think is almost worse than what they
were doing before when our anthem is
played I'm done I'm ready to go to
college football Saturday's my football
day tell us what happened with the
Eagles well there's a lot to unpack
there but let me just say the president
could not be more clear on his position
on the national anthem he's made a very
simple request he thinks people should
stand for the flag and before people
yell and say everybody did stand for the
flag nobody took a knee last year that's
not what this particular incident was
about this was a decision the president
made based on how this particular event
was handled not based on what happened
last season and may I remind everyone it
is the NFL not the White House and not
the president who came out with a brand
new policy that governs what its players
will do that's between the NFL and its
and its ball clubs in its players and
they came out with a policy last month
that perhaps some of some of the players
on different teams don't like Sean I
think the president was focused on the
right number and that was the 1,000
evils fans at at RSVP to the White House
many of whom we were told were already
in town expecting to come to the White
House so he decided to respect their
effort in coming in their excitement and
still welcome them to the White House
but to convert it into a celebrate
America event it was a fabulous event
tonight with them with today with the
Marine Corps band the Army
course on patriotic songs but look there
are lots of Eagles players who voted for
Donald Trump who support many of his
policies they just don't come forward
and say that we got a role we love
having you on thank you for clarifying
all of the